all right let's get into a couple other
uh different things there's a clip
that's been making the rounds from a
republican Town Hall Republicans in the
house have been doing this commitment to
America agenda rollout town halls and
it's all weird and they're trying to
pretend like they care about policy
again but the policy is all just
cultural issues and random nonsense so
at this event and House minority leader
Congressman Kevin McCarthy was at this
event a woman gets up you know a
concerned mom in the audience the the a
prototypical concerned mom and she lists
a whole bunch of things that she
believes are really Marxism and in that
list she includes not bullying people
not bullying people is Marxism according
to this Republican mom supposedly and
this is a there is so much behind this
that I want to talk about it but first
let's take a look at the clip and you'll
notice if you're watching that as she
talks about this Kevin McCarthy kind of
nods along like this makes sense there
are many other public education issues
concerning parents like myself
the slow creep of critical race Theory
diversity equity and inclusion right
gender identity and allowing biological
boys to enter girls spaces and sports
now we have SEL which is social
emotional learning
it's indoctrination disguised as promo
programs like kindness initiatives or
anti-bullying programs anti-bullying
exams or diversity projects
these are all marks of style programs
targeting our children yeah
so listen there there's a lot going on
here and there's many many many layers
now at the most superficial level
if you've watched the Trump rally it
does kind of seem like Republicans are
okay with bullying that I don't know
that I would say pro-bullying maybe so
but they're at least okay with it you
know Trump would get him the hell out of
here Trump's saying to people in the
crowd he'll pay their legal bills if
they beat the crap out of protesters at
the rallies making fun of the disabled
reporter I mean there's bullying of All
Sorts never mind this entire like beta
male type stuff that they subscribe to
so one part of it is they do seem to buy
into this kind of strict father morality
idea that getting knocked around a
little bit getting bullied whatever it
builds character it toughens you up it
makes people strong or whatever the case
maybe rather than you know it can really
kind of Scar people for life and ruin
their lives irreparably in some cases so
that that's one part of it which is they
actually do seem to sort of be okay with
bullying to some degree number one
number two
this is part of the growing movement
that empathy is bad empathy is not
desirable empathy is uh feminine in some
way or beta or whatever and that's been
increasingly a part of Republican
ideology for a long time facts don't
care about your feelings it's a popular
line listen things just are what they
are you got to call things what they are
you got to call a man a man no matter
what you've got to call you know these
are the phrases that they love to use
where empathy is a bad thing now
I don't know that they're unable to be
empathetic because we do anecdotally
hear about these stories where you know
homophobic member of Congress for 20
years turns out they've got a lesbian
daughter or you know a gay
um nephew or something like that and all
of a sudden they they change their view
so in those cases we say it's really sad
that it took something like that to get
them to change their views but they were
at least able to so maybe maybe it's not
just about an inability to feel empathy
but then we have all of these studies
about the differences between what end
up being Republican brains or Democratic
brains and we see on the Republican side
larger fear centers uh less empathy Etc
now I think one of the things that can
be deceptive about that is
it's not about
Republican and Democratic brains per se
it's more about
who's more fear oriented
who's more anger oriented who's more
discussed oriented they end up being on
the political right which in the United
States pushes you towards the Republican
party and if you consider that maybe
there is some kind of neurological or
biological explanation here but then the
Counterpoint to that is sometimes when
they experience something themselves
their views do change what I don't like
is that this is all kind of a cover for
the fact that they're mad that in some
circles it's not seen as acceptable to
openly bully people who are in some way
different than the majority it's not
okay in some places anymore thankfully
to openly bully LGBT people a lot of
them don't like that minorities in many
cases they would still they they like
the uh idea of the days where it was
okay to more openly bully or poorly
treat minorities and and now they're
upset it's considered woke that you
can't do that anymore that's at the Crux
of all of this stuff and absent policy
because the Republican party has given
up on policy that when's the last time
you heard a serious discussion
involving Republicans about what tax
rates should be
they don't do it anymore
it's gone they're just not doing it
anymore when is the last time they
genuinely talked productively about uh
American foreign policy other than just
criticizing Biden because he both didn't
do enough and did too much by spending
too much money when it comes to Ukraine
they don't even pretend to be about
policy anymore this new movement where
this mom concerned mom spoke it's them
pretending to care about policy again
even though they clearly don't and it's
just about bemoaning the fact that they
can't treat all the same people horribly
that they used to treat horribly truly
disgusting stuff